قال مسؤول السياسات الخارجيه في الاتحاد
الاوروبي جزاء البوريل ان من الواضح ان
الصين تستعد لمرحله جديده تعزيز فيها
سياستها الخارجيه والداخليه
اعتماد الدول الاوروبيه على الصين واضحه
ولكن في نفس الوقت لدى العديد من الدول
الاعضاء علاقات اقتصاديه وثيقه مع الصين
وخلص الى انه لا يمكن وضع الصين على نفسي
مستوى مع روسيا حسب تعبيره
التي استمرت لي يومين وتصدره الحرب
الروسيه الاخرانيه اجنده الاجتماع
بالاضافه لعلاقه الاتحاد الاوروبي مع
الصين
الكبرى بمزيد من التنسيق على المستوى
الاوروبي في ملف الهجره مؤكد الوزير عبر
تويتر
هذا هو يختفي اليوم وزراء خارجيه الدول
مجموعه السبع اجتماعهم كما ذكرنا الذي
استمر ليومين عن هذا طبعا هذا الاجتماع مع
مراسل الجزيره من هناك عيسى طيب عيسى اذن
ركز على مساله العلاقه مع الصين ماذا عن
بقيه الملفات المطروحه في هذا الاجتماع
عندما سئل هذا السؤال عن عن الجندي التي
طالب بها وزيره الخارجيه الالمانيه
التعامل مع الصين وروسيا على قدم المساواه
عندما قالت ينبغي نتعلم من اخطائنا وعدم
الاعتماد على دول لا تشاطرنا هذه القيم
كان يرده بان لا يمكن وضع الصين في منزلته
روسيا والفوارق كبيره جدا
الدول الاوروبيه لها شركات اقتصاديه ضخمه
ولا امر مختلف تماما مع روسيا لربما هذه
جزء من الاختلافات التي ظهرت في بعض
الملفات في في مصر وخصوصا بطله الهجره همم
كما شرط مريم في الخبر بان وزير الخارجيه
الايطالي الذي هو ايضا يشغل منصب نائب
رئيس وزراء رئيس وزراء ايطاليا وينتمي الى
اليمين الوسط ايضا حول الضغط على مجموعات
السبع بان يكون المسار نحو الت في مساله
اللاجئين لكن ال- ال- القضايا المتفق
عليها والتي تم اتخذ فيها خطوات هي ملف
ايران ايران الان انتن بليك الوزير
الخارجيه الامريكي ونظارتها ايه ال- ال-
الالمانيه اكد تماما بان العمل على تجديد
العقوبات على ايران العمل على مساعده
الايرانيين وهو هو الاتفاق الذي ينبغي ان
نعمل عليه ايضا علامات وصفه ايضا وزير
الخارجيه الامريكي انتم لبرين كان بان
مجموعته واداراته تعمل الان على تفعيل
مساله مساهمه التكنولوجيا في التواصل بين
الايرانيين وتخطي الحجم الذي تمارسه
الحكومه الايرانيه ايضا وزيرت الخارجيه
الالمانيه تحدثت عن مثل دعم المجموعات
السبع لاوكرانيا في هذا الشتاء هناك اتفاق
على الدعم المستعجل لاوكرانيا خصوصا في
مساله تزويدها بالمولدات بالاغاثه
المباشره لتجاوز هذه المحنه هناك اخبار
تقول في في الاجتماع مجموعه السبع بان
اغلب محطات الطاقه والمولدات تم استهدافها
وبالتالي كما قالت انا لينا بيربك وزيره
الخارجيه الالمانيه نحاول ان ان ان ان ان
ان ان ان ان ان ندعم الاوكرانيين حتى لا
يجوع ولا يبرد في هذا الشتاء القضايا
الدوليه الاخرى طبعا كثيره ومتعدده ولكن
ينبغي ان نشير ايضا الى الاختلافات
البينيه بين الافراد وبين الدول المشاركه
خصوصا في مسائل تتحدث عن مساله التعامل مع
الطاقه مع هناك ايضا توافق على مساله
الطاقه الروسيه ومساله تحديد السعر لكن
هناك اختلافات بيننا في مساله تسعيره
الغاز لا تزال المانيا متشبثه برؤيتها بان
تسعيره الغاز قد تفقدوا اوروبا امتيازاتها
وتدفق الغاز من دول اخرى لذلك يحاول
القائمون الان تجنب محاور الخلاف والذهاب
الى محاوره للالتقاء ربما اخيرا وهو سبب
اختيار المانيا هذه المدينه موستر وهذه
القاعه تحديدا
لاقامه هذا الاجتماع هذه القاعه هي قاعات
التي شاهدت معاهده همم معاهده انهاء حرب
30 عاما عام
1648 والتي انهت الصدام والصراع بين
الامبراطوريه الاوروبيه وبين ملوك الطوائف
الالمان وبالتالي تعتبر مرحبا مفصليه في
تاريخ اوروبا الحديث نعم ايضا شكرا جزيلا
لك